Speaker 1: This is an unbelievable clip, though.
I'm going to show you an unbelievable clip here
on Fox and Friends this morning. Steve Doocy
seemed to be sending a message to Donald Trump
to stop inciting violence against the
fbi. Why would steve doocy do this? Well,
because it's not looking very good for what are
obviously trumpists. It's not liberals threatening
the fbi as a result of the fbi executing a
search warrant at mar a lago. It's trumpists
and steve doocy. I guess trying to make right
wingers not look so violent and horrible
suggested that it would be great if Trump would
call to an end to the violent rhetoric towards
law enforcement. But what's not getting headlines
about this clip is that Doocy seems to be saying,
really, your ire should be directed at
the attorney general, Merrick Garland.
I agree that Doocy seems to be saying we got to
stop the violence against the fbi agents. They
were just doing their job. But in this very clip,
he seems to be suggesting that it is legitimate
to put your focus on Merrick Garland. Take
a look at this. It's unbelievable that this
is what's happening in this country.
Speaker 2: We just know that right now,
given the fact that there is a suggestion
that there are a lot of online very specific,
apparently very specific threats against very
specific agents at the FBI and whatnot. It would
it would be great for everybody to tamp down
the the rhetoric against the FBI, because the
FBI simply was doing what the DOJ asked them
to do. The attorney general is the boss of the
guy at the FBI, of all the people at the FBI. So,
you know, with all of these threats going around,
it would ultimately be great if the
former president, who has always been
a great supporter of law enforcement.
Speaker 1: Well, that's not even really
true. He's been a supporter of law enforcement
when it's convenient to his political goals. But,
okay, let's not focus in on that.
Speaker 2: As opposed with a thousand
police departments coast to coast. It would be
great if he called for an end to the violent
rhetoric against federal law enforcement and in
particular, the FBI that was just doing their job.
Speaker 1: All right. So so far, okay. I
guess raising call for an end to the violence.
Speaker 2: But as Trey Gowdy pointed out
last night, for you to look at this situation
and think that Democrats and Republicans have
been treated the same over the last few years,
you have to be looking at a different situation.
Speaker 1: Right. It's the Justice Department.
That's what they're going to do. She says
the FBI agents were just doing their job
as directed by the DOJ. The DOJ is really to
blame and kill me. Jumps in and says, and it is.
And they are very in a very partizan manner. The
DOJ doesn't treat Democrats and Republicans the
same, a claim for which there is no evidence.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, diamonds for all.
Speaker 3: Talked about that too. We
said, you know, it's interesting that the
Democrats are progressives are now worried about
protecting law enforcement when they weren't,
you know, years ago during the raids. But no one
is for the violence of FBI agents or, you know,
any of these individuals that are in law. Right.
Speaker 2: If you want to personify that search,
look at the attorney general of the United States,
Merrick Garland is there. It is, guys, that.
Speaker 1: If you want to personify.
Okay, what he's saying is really the
person responsible here is Merrick Garland.
That's where your ire should be directed. Oh,
okay. So don't do the violence against the FBI
agents, then just focus in on Merrick Garland.
Speaker 2: The one who has staked his entire
reputation on it. If there's something if there's
not something really big there, he's done.
Speaker 1: Okay. So, I mean, listen, it's.
I'll give him credit. The. Doxing of individual
FBI agents who are just doing their jobs and
executing a legal search warrant with
all of the I's dotted and t's crossed.
The approval of Garland. The approval of
Trump's own FBI Director, Christopher Wray.
The signature of a judge. Those are not the people
that we should actually be holding responsible.
But that doesn't mean go after Merrick Garland and
of course, the DOJ and Merrick Garland receiving
death threats and everything of everything
you would expect these Trumpists would do.
They did over the weekend. So you almost had it,
Steve. But now you're saying focus in on Garland.
These people are truly disgusting. And but to
their credit, they know their audience. They
know their audience wants blood. They know that.
And he's, I guess, to some degree, trying to focus
that desire on people other than the FBI agents.
We'll have this clip on her Instagram. If you want
to see it, you can find that at The David Pakman
Show. We'll take a quick break and be right back.